Tung thư, chú vị nước lương cường thân này với đến các chào thiếu niên,
đi đồng ở khám mọi miệnh tổ quốc,
các cháo người Việt Nam ở nước ngoài,
những tình cảm yêu thương lời tham hỏi anh cân và lời chút tôi đẹp nhớ.
Tết Trung Thu từ bao đời này,
đã trở thành nhất đẹp không thể thiếu trong đời sống găn hóa của người Việt Nam.
Đây là dịp để các chào huy trời,
xuống học, quay quần bên gia đình bạn bẹ.
Tuy nhiên, chú vị nước cũng chia sẻ rằng,
năm nay, nhiều đều quyền trên đất nước ta,
phải gồm mình chống cho ai với báo lũ,
người lớn, cáo dài,
người thiệt hại to lớn, vình rồi và tài sản,
anh rưởng nặng nè tới đời sống,
xin hoạt và học tập của các cháo.
Chú tính nước chia sẻ và người lời hỏi tham sâu sắc nhất,
đến các cháo và ra đình đang chữ anh rưởng của thiên tay.
Chú tính nước tìm tưởng rằng,
với sự phán tâm trong loa của đàn,
nhắn nước và tình thân đoàn kết,
yêu thương, sự đùm bọc của cả rất tộc,
các cháo của mạc dành sẽ vượt qua khó khăn,
sớm mồn định cuộc sống,
tiếp tục học tập,
vui chơi và nguy rửa ước mơ của mình.
Đàn, nhắn nước và tàn xác hội,
luôn dành sự quan tâm đặc biệt cho các cháo,
luôn tạo mọi điều kiện tốt nhất để các cháo được học tập,
danh luệp, vui chơi ăn toàn và phát triển tàn dẹp.
Chú tính nước mong các cháo luôn dữ vững tình thân yếu học,
luôn chăm quan, đoàn kết, yêu thương và chia sẻ.
Dù đưới nhau cùng tiếng bộ,
cùng nhau chừng thành để đóng có không sức,
sẽ giữ đất nước Việt Nam thân yêu của chúng ta,
này thang zau đẹp, văn mình.
Nhân dịp tết chúng thù năm 2018,
chúng tính nước người đến tất cả các cháo niềm tin yêu,
thì vọng chú cất cháo đó nguồn mọi chúng thủ thật ý nghĩa,
ăn toàn ấm áp, mình ra đình, thế cô và bản bệ.
Chú tính nước mong các cháo không được mai mắn,
các cháo ở vùng lũ sẽ luôn cố gắng,
không lối bước trước khó khăn,
các cháo hãy giữ nụ cười mại hội dân trong sáng,
thấp lên những ước mơ thật tư đẹp để sau cơn báo
cuộc sống lại chân nó phải sáng và nè buổi.